[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
ترامب يصل الى نيويورك اليوم وجهازه
الخدمه السريه يرافقه الى مكتب المدعي
العام لبدء محاكمته غدا
يجدد القول ان انتخابات عام 2020 مزوره
ومسروقه ويتعهد باستعادتها في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله
[تصفيق]
روسيا تعلن عن تعزيز وجودها العسكري في
الغرب والشمال الغربي بعد انضمام فنلندا
الى حلف الناتو
اهلا بكم من المتوقع ان يغادر الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فلوريدا ظهر
الاثنين بتوقيت شرق الولايات المتحده على
ان تهبط طائرته في مطار لاغوارديا في
نيويورك عند الثالثه من بعد الظهر على ان
يغادر نيويورك فور توجيه الاتهامات له يوم
غد للعوده الى فلوريدا ومع قرب المحاكمه
فقد تم ايقاف جميع المحاكمات ومعظم انشطه
المحكمه الاخرى قبل الموعد المقرر لوصول
ترامب
وسيقوم جهاز الخدمه السريه واداره شرطه
نيويورك وضباط المحكمه بتنسيق الاجراءات
الامنيه لظهور الرئيس السابق المتوقع كما
انه من المقرر ان ترافق الشرطه السريه
ترامب الى مكتب المدعي العام
وسيتم حجز ترامب من قبل المحققين وهذا
يشمل اخذ البصمات وقد لا يتم اخذ صورته او
لقطه حقيقيه له بحكم انه شخصيه معروفه على
نطاق واسع وفق مصادر مطلعه على هذه
الاستعدادات عدا عن قلق السلطات من تسريب
محتمل غير مناسب للصوره اذا ما تم
التقاطها وهذا سيكون انتهاكا لقانون
الدوله كما ان القاضي لم يوافق على طلب
تغطيه وسائل الاعلام لهذه الاجراءات
ويعتبر الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الذي
يترشح للرئاسه مره ثانيه في العام 20 24
اول رئيس امريكي يتهم بارتكاب جنايه
جنائيه
الاستعداد لمعركه هذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دانل ترامب قبل جلسه
محاكمته المقرره الثلاثاء وفق محاميه من
المتوقع ان يسافر ترامب الى مدينه نيويورك
برفقه اعضاء من الخدمه السريه الامريكيه
من منزله في مارلاجو الاثنين ثم يخطط
للعوده الى فلوريدا بعد جلسه محاكمته حيث
سيخاطب انصاره بحسب محاميه ستحارب اي
اتهامات ضد الرئيس السابق بقوه وسيمثل
امام محكمه نيويورك لابلاغه بتهمه جنائيه
موجهه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
اباحيه بغيه شراء صمتها من المتوقع ان
يسلم نفسه للسلطات يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المقرر عقد جلسه ظهرا في منهات ولن تقيد
يدات ترامب وبحسب محاميه التفاصيل الاخرى
للاستدعاء لا تزال غامضه بحكمه انه امر
غير مسبوق لا تزال تفاصيل التهم بما في
ذلك ماهيتها وعددها طي الكتمان وفق محاميه
وصى نفيا بارتكابها من قبل ترامب تقارير
اعلاميه افادت بان ترامب سيواجهه اكثر من
30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري لدفع 130
الف دولار
في محاوله لشراء صمتها بشان علاقه جنسيه
مزعومه
وسائل اعلام امريكيه ذكرت بان ترامب متهم
بتزوير سجلات تجاريه من الدرجه الاولى وهي
جنايه بموجب القانون الامريكي ومن المقرر
تنظيم تجمع حاشد لترامب مع النائبه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب مارجريت هيلر
جرين ظهر الثلاثاء بنيويورك داعيه ان صار
ترامب للانضمام الى احتجاج سلمي ضد لائحه
الاتهام رش خياط العربيه
ومن امام محكمه نيويورك في منهت المراسل
العربيه طلال الحاج متواجد ليوفينا بمزيد
من المعلومات طلال اهلا وسهلا بك المشهد
من امام المحكمه كيف يبدو طلال وما
المتوقع غدا هل نتوقع مفاجات مدويه كما
قال البعض ام لا هذه مبالغات
لا نعرف في واقع الام طالب هل هناك ستكون
اعمال العنف
نرجو ان لا يكون كذلك الرئيس الامريكي
السابق لدوله ترامب حذر من الناس ستكون
هناك
اعمال العنف ولكن
لم يطالب ولكن هذا ما يتوقعه هنا الشرطه
في
مجيد وهي اكبر جهاز شرطه في اي مدينه
امريكيه مستعد لهذه الاحداث
الاجراءات الامنيه هنا حولي مكثفه جدا
هناك
اجهزه لكشف الاسلحه اذا كان
المتظاهر قادما وما حو سلاح مخبا في ذاته
هناك الكاميرات باعداد كبيره
اجراءات الامنيه لم لم الامر حتى اثناء
احياء ذكرى او الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
ما نعرفه الان ان سيصل هذا بعد الظهر
اليوم سيطير من
مالوراجو مالا راجو وهو في ولايه مراكا
وفي ولايه فلوريدا علمتني طائره الخاصه
وسيذهب فورا الى مقر منزله في نيويورك
نتوقع وصولها حوالي الساعه الثالثه بعد
الظهر هنا في نيويورك وسيكون في منزله في
شارع افينيو
غدا سياتي الى هنا صباحا الساعه السادسه
عشره بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
المحلي وسيدخل هذه المحكمه ورائي من باب
جانبي
الطابق الخامس عشر وهو الطابق الوحيد
العامل في هذا المبنى حيث ستوقف المحاكم
جميع القضايا في جميع المحاكم
المحكمه كاحترازات امنيه
سيتمون اخذ رسوماته اما بالنسبه للتصوير
فهو ما زال قيد التفاوض بين محاميه
والادعاء العام في المحكمه
صرح بانهم ما زالوا يتفاوضون حول
الاجراءات مثلثات
طالب ولا نعرف كيف ستتم الجميع وانت تتحدث
فقط
ربما هنالك تشويش من بعض الاجهزه اجهزه
الحمايه السريه في في المكان طلال سالتك
عن يعني ترامب ما زال يحظى بشعبيه
وله مؤيدون كثر هل ثمت تحضيرات وتجمعات من
انصاره للقيام بتحرك ما بالقرب من المحكمه
في محاوله للضغط على الادعاء العام ام لا
حتى الساعه لم ترى مثل هكذا تحركات في
الشارع
ربما تكون هنا بعض الظهر
او صباح
مظاهره صغيره ولكن المظاهره الكبرى ستكون
يوم غد والتي دعت اليها النائبه المتطرفه
للظهور هنا ودعوه الجميع الدعوه على
الانترنت لجميع للحضور الى هذه الحديقه
الشرطه نيويورك مستعده
للتعامل مع هؤلاء المتظاهرين اذا استخدم
العنف
عمده المدينه
عدم
واكد انهم مستعدون
لحمايه الرئيس كذلك حمايه الشعب هنا
المواطنين الذي يقيمون في في هذه المدينه
القاضي اخوان مرشان وهاجم المدعي العام
ابراج
ولكن القاضي معروف
في
معروفه عن الجديه الكامله والحنك
القانونيه
وبانسانيته في واقع الامر ولكن يقول ترامب
ان هذا القاضي يكرهه تماما ويحقد عليه
لجنه المحلفين في هذه المحكمه هي من قررت
الخميس الماضي توجيه التهم الى الرئيس
السابق وعددهم تقريبا 20 محلفا وليس
المدعي العام
هذا الملف
الماضيه عندما استلم هذا المنصب من سيف
فانس الذي بدا هذا التحقيق عندما كان
ترامب رئيسا
عام 2018
هذه الاجراءات
فقط يعني المعلومات المتواتره المعلومات
المتواتره انه الرئيس ترامب متاكد بانه
سيوجه اليه اتهام وسيعود مجددا وبشكل سريع
الى فلوريدا بمعنى انه لن يتم اعتقاله باي
شكل من الاشكال اعضاء ديمقراطيون سمعت
سمعتم وقرات لهم اليوم وهم قانونيون
يقولون ان القانونيين في نيويورك جمعوا
وثائق تثبت ادانه الرئيس السابق دون ترامب
من حتى قبل الاعلان على الاتهامات وهنالك
احتمال كبير لاعتقاله الى اي مدى يعني
يعني هاتان الفرضيتان اي فرضيه يمكن
ترجيحها غدا ام لا هذا رجم في الغيب
الفرضيه المرجحه هو انه سيمثل امام القاضي
في قصيره يعني عشر دقائق ربع ساعه لا اكثر
سيعرض عليه التهم ويعرض عليه قراءتها في
الغالب
لا تقراها واعطينا الاتهامات حتى الان حتى
المحامي ترامب لم يروا هذه التهم في واقع
الامر
وبالتالي يتم الافراج عنه وسيتوجه بعد
الظهر غدا على على الفور الى
منزلي هناك في فلوريدا وسيلقي بخطاب
الساعه الرابعه والربع بتوقيت دبي حول هذه
الاجراءات التي تمت اليوم
لذلك ما هو حتى الان متوقع
لنيوك فور انتهاء هذه الاجراءات التي
ستبدا نحو الساعه الثانيه والربع بالتوقيت
المحلي او العاشره والربع بتوقيته دبي
فكل ذلك طبعا هناك
استفاده كبيره للترمت من هذه الاجراءات
تمكن من جمع خمسه ملايين
شعبيته الان متفوق على اقرب مناسبيه
طيب ساعود اليك طلال ابقى معي لنسمع ما
قاله الرئيس ترامب اعزائي المشاهدين
الرئيس الامريكيه السابق كان قد قال ان
انتخابات عام 2020 مزوره ومسروقه مشددا
على ضروره استعادتها في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله عام 2020 مشيرا ايضا الى
ان الهجمات التي استهدفته لم يشهدها اي
رئيس اخر في تاريخ امريكا
لم يتعرض اي رئيس في تاريخ بلدنا لمثل هذه
الهجمات الشرسه والمثيره
لكنهم يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم
هذا بسيط جدا لا يمكنهم شرائي ولا يمكنهم
التحكم به وهذا يخيفهم بشكل لا يصدق تمويل
حملاتنا الرئاسيه دائما كان من قبل
الوطنيين من القاعده الشعبيه مثلكم
مساهمتكم اليوم ستظهر لليسار انه لا شيء
يمكن ان يدمر اعظم حركه سياسيه في التاريخ
حققنا اداء افضل بعده ملايين وملايين
الاصوات في عام 2020 لكن الانتخابات تم
تزويرها وسرقتها ولكن اليوم سنستعيد بلدنا
في عام
اعود الى مراسل العربيه طلال الحاج هو
متواجد من امام المحكمه محكمه نيويورك في
منهاته طلال اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ما زال مصرا على سرديه ان
الانتخابات عام 2020 كانت مزوره ومسروقه
وانه تعرض
لحملات لم يتعرض لها اي رئيس في تاريخ
امريكا طيب الكلام المنتشر الان يعني مع
بدء هذه المحاكمات على ان ثمه توجه ما
لرفع بطاقه حمراء بوجه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب والقول له نوقف محاكمه
الاتهامات والمحاكمات مقابل ان تسحب
ترشيحك تماما وتخرج من الحياه السياسيه
الى اي مدى هذا الكلام منتشر ويملك مؤيدين
ومصداقيه في الولايات المتحده طلب
مناصرون ترامب بالطبع يعتمد الانتخابات
السابقه مسروقه وان بايدن فاز بها وان هذه
المحكمه ورائي وهذه
يقولون انها بسبب عزمه خوض الانتخابات
الرئيسيه القادمه عام 20 24 وهو المرشح
المفوض للفوز بالترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
الشخصيات الجمهوريه
ايضا مثل
زعيم الجمهوري الحاليين في مجلس النواب
وحتى منافسي المتوقع في سباق الرئاسه حاكم
ولايه
لا ننسى يجب
ان مايكل كون محامي ترم وجهت اليه تهم
مشابهه في قبل في عام 2018
وادين بها بانها تهم اجراميه ودخل السجن ل
13 شهرا
وقت سجن او اقامه جبريه لمده سنه ونصف
مايكل كون كان سيسري على ترامب لولا انه
كان رئيسا واصرت وزاره العدل في ذلك الوقت
على ان لا يحاكم او توجه الى هذه
نعم تاجيلها نعم ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
امام محكمه نيويورك في منهات المراسل
العربيه الحاج وعذرا اعزائي المشاهدين على
الصوت المتقطع نتيجه التشويش من قبل
الاجهزه الاجهزه الامن السريه العامله
والمكلفه باجراءات هذه المحاكمه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
جزء لا يتجزا من اراضيها
اهلا بكم من جديد قال نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه الكسندر جروشكو ان بلاده ستعزز من
وجودها العسكريه على الحدود الغربيه
والشماليه الغربيه وذلك ردا على انضمام
فنلندا الى حلف الناتو واوضح جرشكو ان
روسيا ستتخذ خطوات اضافيه لضمان امنها
العسكري عند نشر قوات ومعدات لاي عضو
للنيتو في
من جهه اخرى قال امين عام ان الحلف لا
يشعر بالخوف من تهديدات روسيا النوويه
وسيواصل دعم اوكرانيا كما اشار الى ان
الناتو لم يلحظ اي تحركات في روسيا متعلقه
بتغيير وضعها النووي واضاف الامين العام
للنيتو ان اعضاء الحلف ارسلوا لاوكرانيا
مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه 65
مليار دولار
هذا وقعنا مكتب الرئيس الفنلندي ان البلاد
ستصبح عضوا رسميا في حلف شمال الاطلسي غدا
الثلاثاء واضاف مكتب الرئيس الفنلندي ان
جميع دول حلف الناتو البالغ عددها 30 دوله
صادقت على بروتوكول انضمام فنلندا للنيتو
لتصبح العضو الواحد والثلاثين واظهرت
لقطات لاعلام الدول الاعضاء امام مدخل
مبنى الناتو تتوسطها ساريه في انتظار رفع
علم فنلندا بين هذه الدول
هذا اسبوع تاريخي للنيتو غدا سنعلن
ترحيبنا بانضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو العضو
رقم واحد وثلاثين ما سيجعل من فنلندا اكثر
امانا هو الحلف سيزداد قوه كذلك السويد
ستصبح اكثر امنا وكان هذا نتاج الدعوه
التي قدمها النيتو لانضمام فنلندا والسويد
للحلف العام الماضي وكانت اجراءات اتمامها
سريعه بالنسبه للحلف وكلنا نتفق على ضروره
انهاء اجراءات انضمام السويد بشكل سريع
قرر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي اقاله وزير
الدفاع بسبب الوضع الامني في البلاد وافاد
مراسل العربيه بان نتنياهو لم يقل جالنت
رسميا ولم يسلمه رساله اقاله خطيه موقعه
بل ابلغه بذلك شفهيا
وفي شان متصل اعلن قاده الائتلاف الحكومي
في اسرائيل وقاده المعارضه في تصريح مشترك
ان هناك تفاؤلا حذرا بشان المحادثات التي
جرت بينهما في منزل الرئيس الاسرائيلي
التصريح المشترك اكد اتفاق الطرفين على
ضروره الوصول الى حل طويل الامل مع توضيح
ان كل الاطراف الاسرائيليه تدرك معنى عظام
التوصل الى اتفاق وطني واضاف التصريح
المشترك ان المحادثات ستستانف بعد عطله
عيد الفصح
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اعلنت وزاره الصحه
مقتل شابين فلسطينيين برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه خلال اقتحامها حي المخفيه في
نابلس
وافاد مراسل العربيه بوقوع الشبكات واطلاق
نار خلال عمليه الاقتحام وذكرت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه انه تم اعتقال شبين اثنين
خلال مداهمه احد المباني بذريعه الاشتباه
في ضلوعهما بعمليه اطلاق النار الاخيره في
حواره
شددت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج على ضروره التزام امريكا
بمبدا صين واحده والتزام القوانين
المشتركه بينهما مؤكده ان تايوان جزء لا
يتجزا من الصين
اؤكد انه لا يوجد سوى صين واحده في العالم
ومنطقه تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من الصين اكد
الجاريم الصيني مرارا وتكرارا معارضه
الاجتماعات الرسميه بين الولايات المتحده
وتايوان يجب على ممثلي الولايات المتحده
المعنيين الالتزام بمبدا صين واحده
والقوانين المشتركه الثلاثه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده والامتناع عن ارسال
اشارات خاطئه الى استقلال تايوان والقوات
الانفصاليه حتى لا تضر بالعلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه ستتخذ الصين اجراءات مضاده
صارمه لحمايه سيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين في السعوديه عن
نجاح خطتها في استقبال الاعداد المليونيه
للمعتمرين والزوار والمصلين خلال الايام
العشر الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك وياتي
نجاح الخطه التي وضعتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين في وقت تشهد فيه كافه الخدمات
الميدانيه والاداريه تميزا كبيرا رغم
زياده اعداد المعتمرين في الحرمين اضافه
الى نوعيه الخدمات البشريه والتقنيه التي
حققت رضا كبيرا للقاصدين الى الحرمين
الشريفين
معي من الحرم المكي الشريف وراسي العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد من عندك اسامه وابرز مشاهداتك
اليوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا طالب تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدي قناه العربيه نعم اعلنت رئاسه
الشؤون الحرمين عن نجاح الخطه التشغيليه
للعشره الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك التي
ايضا جاء من ضمنها استكمال تهيئه اعمال
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بما فيها
بمصلياتها وساحاتها اترككم الان مع لقطات
من التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه وبالتحديد من
منتصف هذه التوسعه باب مئه الذي يعتبر
الباب الرئيسي للدخول والخروج من التوسعه
السعوديه الثالث طبعا هذه الخطه ايضا جاءت
ضمن عدد من الخدمات المقدمه للزوار
والمعتمرين كتقديم مياه زمزم التي بلغت
عدد النترات التي قدمت للزوار المعتمرين
اكثر من 12 مليون لترا ايضا منها تنظيف
سجاد المسجد الحرام وايضا تقديم عدد من
الخدمات للحجاج للمعتبرين ايضا هناك نقطه
مهمه ان ايضا الخدمات المقدمه للزوار
والمعتمرين داخل اروقه المسجد الحرام
وخارج اروقه المسجد الحرام تاتي ضمن خطه
تشغيليه كامله لان يعيشوا تجربه متك الى
داخل المسجد الحرام وخارجي في هذه الايام
المباركه طبعا رئيس شؤون الحرمين اعلن عن
نجاح الخطه التي جاءت ضمن شراكه مع عدد من
الجهات منها الخطه الامنيه والخطه
التشغيليه وخطه ايضا النظافه وسقيا زمزم
هذه المنطقه التي نقف بها الان هي منطقه
الوسط التي تشهد ازدحاما للان وما زال
ازدحام ايضا في ازدياد خلال الساعات
القائمه لاداء صلاه التراويح طبعا عدد
المعتمرين والزوار الذين وصلوا الى مكه
المكرمه تم عدهم قبل يومين بتسعه فاصله
اربعه مليون زائر ومعتمر هذه الاعداد
بالتاكيد انها قابله للزياده خلال الايام
القادمه اسامه عندما تجول في بحات الحرم
تلتقي الناس تسالهم هل كل الامور تتم بيسر
وسهوله ولا يكدر صفوها شيئا ام لا في
البعض ربما لديه بعض الملاحظات
اعتقد طالب ان جميع الخدمات المقدمه حصلت
على رضا الكثير من الزوار والمعتمرين جميع
من لقيناهم في هذه الفتره حتى اثناء
تجولنا في ساحات المسجد الحرام كلهم
يشيدون بهذه الخدمات المقدمه السعوديه
قدمت جهودا كبيرا جدا لان تخرج مكه
المكرمه بموسم العمره والحج بشكل ممتاز
يحوز على رضا الجمع من خلال الخدمات
المقدمه وايضا تيسير الوصول والخروج من
المسجد الحرام والى خارج نتحدث اليوم طالب
عن الحافلات التردديه التي تنقل الزوار
والمعتمرين من الحرم الى فنادقهم والعكس
كذلك نتحدث ايضا عن الشركات شركات العمره
التي لابد ان تكون مرخصه وموثوقه وتقدم
خدمات ممتازه للزوار والمعتمرين الجميع
اليوم يعيش هذه الحاله الكبيره جدا من
الرضا في ساحات المسجد الحرام فقط ازدحام
هي من تعمل نوعا من الخروج والدخول
وازدحام شديد جدا خصوصا في اوقات الصلاه
ولكن هذا متوقع جدا الخطه الامنيه ايضا
لها خطه متوازنه مع اعداد المعتمرين
واعداد الزوار على مدار الثلاثين يوما في
شهر رمضان المبارك ممتاز من الحرم المكي
الشريف وراس العربي اسامه القاسم شكرا
جزيلا لك اسامه على كل هذه المتابعه
اخيرا في نشره الخامسه قام العلماء بتصوير
سمكه تسبح على عمق غير عادي في المحيط
الهادي قباله جنوب اليابان ما يجعلها اعمق
ملاحظه من هذا النوع يتم اجراؤها على
الاطلاق وقد تم تصوير سمكه الحلزون وهي
تسبح على عمق ثمانيه الاف
وثلاثين مترا وبحسب الخبراء فان هذه
السمكه قد تكون قريبه جدا من اقصى عمق
يمكن لاي سمكه البقاء على قيد الحياه حيث
تم اجراء اعمق ملاحظه سابقه للاسماك على
عمق
8178 مترا وبالتالي فان هذا الاكتشاف يفوق
الرقم القياسي للعمق بمقدار
178 مت
[موسيقى]
را
نشاط الخامسه انتهت اطيبه تحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]